Speaker 1: OK, let's get into audience questions,
the first one, one that I am asked so often,
David, why does it appear to be more profitable
to be a right wing grifter than it does to
be a left wing grifter, either someone who
pretends to have changed sides or have a political
awakening or simply put out ideas that even
they don't believe merely because it makes
money?
There are two reasons why right wing grifting
is so much more popular than left wing grifting.
The the two reasons are, number one, the left
doesn't really care about people who have
these opposite a supposed Awakening's or come
to realize that what they've been fed by their
side is wrong or whatever.
The left doesn't care about it in the same
way.
And number two, there's just less money available
on the left for it.
So we'll explain this one by one, the idea
of someone who used to be on the left and
now is on the right as someone we should pay
particular attention to is much more exciting
to the right.
The left doesn't care.
People call into the show all the time and
say, I had an awakening.
I'm on the left now.
I used to be a right winger.
I fell down the rabbit hole.
It's interesting in the sense that I'm curious,
how did you get out?
Because we know it's tough to get out.
But my reaction is a very muted.
Oh, so you looked at the facts and now you
better understand things.
You're no longer falling for propaganda.
You now understand the real world.
And so, of course, now you're on the same
side I'm on, which is the side of empiricism
and facts and so on and so forth.
Now let's try to get something done.
Let's get the right people elected.
Let's try to fix some problems in society.
What you see on the right is completely different.
When Dave Rubin supposedly had an awakening
from being a burny guy to saying liberalism
is a mental disorder, he was ushered into
Prager.
You to do a video about how he left the left
when Candice Owens I mean, Candice Owens story
is a little more nuanced because for identity
reasons, she's also really interesting to
the right.
But she has this story.
It may be real.
It may be not how she grew up in a Democratic
House.
And I think it was Connecticut or whatever.
And then she figured out all these things.
The right sees that and they celebrated in
some kind of defiant, heroic reaction, whereas
the left, when it happens, just says, oh,
you were you were uninformed.
Great.
Now now you're now you're with us.
But let's go to the next thing.
It's not it's just not as interesting to the
audiences.
And case in point, many people may not remember
Genk Yuga has hosted the Young Turks, has
talked about how when he was young, he was
a reactionary conservative Republican.
He was, I think, in the Republican Club, in
college, whatever.
Every once in a while it comes up, but it
essentially has nothing to do with the success
of the Young Turks like the Young Turks or
not.
It's not predicated on this heroic awakening
that Genk had, which could be a grift or it
might not.
And you just yeah, it seems pretty clear he
was kind of a moderate Republican in college
and now he's not.
OK, that's it.
So the right creates cults of personality
around these people in the way that the left
doesn't.
And it makes it really appealing financially.
OK, second piece money.
There just is more money available for this
stuff on the right than there is on the left.
I've seen it firsthand and we've dealt with
all sorts of different groups.
And there just is on the right.
There are tons of well-funded groups that
love to throw money at people who are doing
the grift, so to speak, these libertarian
groups that pay to bring people to college
campuses.
And you can get nice speaking fees depending
on your level, your profile.
You know, the speaking fee can can be more
or less.
There really isn't much of that on the left.
Of the few times I've been paid to speak at
colleges, it was that the college had like
a donor funded thing of let's bring people
to speak.
There were never groups.
In fact, whenever I get invited by left leaning
groups, they say we have no money organizations
that then will fund, you know, interview series
on different programs in these types of things,
donations as well, even just soliciting the
enlightened centrism.
Tim Poole is an example who raised a ton of
money as someone who said he was like mostly
a burny guy and all this stuff.
But then 90 percent of his content became
criticizing the left and praising Trump.
He raised a whole bunch of money with the
idea that he who had he was on one side, but
he sees this and the other.
And now he's got this whole nice, neat little
package as the arbiter of what's what's right
and what's wrong.
He was able to raise a ton of money on the
idea of launching such a website that would
just give you the news team some.
They figured out how to do the news and people
donated like crazy to it.
That appeals to to right wingers.
And I know someone will say, oh, left on the
left wing, I donated that.
OK, fine.
But the left does not reward that.
That stuff, that type of grifting.
Ideologically, in terms of the cult of personality
around people, nor financially, that's the
explanation as I see it, that's the explanation
as I've experienced it from within.
And remember, I told the story of this radio
consultant who met with me years ago and said,
you know, do you really care about, like,
what you're saying?
Because if you just want to be a performer,
there is a need right now for shows like yours,
you know, at the time, a really young guy.
But on the right, I could get you syndicated
and we could triple your salary.
And I've told that story before.
There was no such thing available to me on
the left.
And I'm glad I turned it down and everything
worked out fine.
No regrets whatsoever.
So those are my thoughts on the profitability
of the left wing graft versus the right wing
grift or the lack thereof when it comes to
the left wing rift.
Send me more thoughts about what you think
might explain that difference